if it airs the way the shop people will
see why I would get up and leave a table
you know Kyle left my party hi Denise
how are you how are you I'm good it's
been about two months since we last did
a quarantine checking how are things
going mrs. Joe I was gonna ask you if I
said last time I'll see if the tequila
intake has opted over the course of the
eight weeks has it good we haven't
reached that point yet yes we know you
and your snacks yes well we got to get
into housewives a little bit we have
reached in I am NOT doing this you guys
we've got I'm stopped bravo Bravo 10
Bravo I'm out
I'm not doing that dinner is upon us
yeah what pushed you to the point where
you felt the need to do that to break
the fourth wall there well first of all
my first week of filming I'm sorry Kyle
I have to say that Kyle was actually the
one that told me to put our hand in
front of our faces
hey bravo Bravo Bravo we didn't want
something that would air so I didn't
make it up I learned from the other
women that I've been before me on the
show many of them did it during my two
seasons at that point at that dinner I
felt that Kyle was was pushing an issue
with me with teddys retreat which was
before which her retreat was a week
after I had surgery I had for hernias
and I had surgery on and I was working
all week on all the beautiful and I
didn't feel physically up to taking in
the entire retreat and I felt that there
was miscommunication on that
you and I was pushing the issue so I did
that to stop to clarify things but our
amazing production before I continued
our so that's what it was
I want a clarification because I all
knew why I wasn't at Teddy's retreat but
early when I showed up I showed up at
dinner and so I just wanted to clarify
things before we continued our dinner
got it you obviously got pushed two
points we did not see in your first
season this season which between the
bravo Bravo moment we see you walk off
we know you didn't show up to a couple
events near the end what changed why did
you get pushed to the place where you
felt the need to kind of those are
drastic measures when you talk about
reality TV I look at this reality and in
my first season I had a great season and
I think it's about getting my feet but
I'm here second season I think I'm a
little bit of a target and that's okay
because we all have a turn for that but
there was a lot of issues that were
brought up in questions that I kept
answering repeatedly and to where I felt
I was like blue in the face answering
those questions swear I had nothing else
to say about it and I'm like alright if
you guys want to keep on talking about
this I can't but there's nothing else to
say then like all in a night I guess
well then she had been honest I was
honest
no I've been on it I'm done Jeanine
no God that's why I left and you know I
didn't stop filming I didn't go to two
different two events that I was asked to
go to your you know finishing this
season I think fans are surprised to
learn it's obviously we heard all this
stuff before the season of what was
gonna unfold now what's playing out is
different than what we thought maybe was
gonna play out it's all these little
moments that are causing these kind of
one of your cast mates call them
earthquakes does it all lead to one
place or was it just that they were
targeting you week after week but you
were just like no well I felt like it
was an issue that kept being brought up
to me several times and I'm one that I
like to just resolve stuff we can agree
to disagree
and move on from it but I felt it kept
like going on and on and on and on and I
and that's nuts enough and I treated as
in real reality I I'm being myself
you want to nothing else at the table
but you know it's obviously I'm just
very committed to the show I filmed with
you know dinner party three days after
having a major surgery and the show is
something that's very important to me so
that's something that I wanted to be
committed to and we know you're still
committed because I saw you filming
those confessionals from home so we're
gonna see the whole thing play out even
up until now
absolutely if if the show continues at
this and is you know I know a lot of
stuff gets cut out because there's so
much footage but if it if it airs the
way the shot people will see why I would
get up and leave a table you know Kyle
left my dinner party maybe alone I'm
done with this mofo these
come on that's wrong goodbye but you'll
see like if it plays out the way we shot
people see and if there's questions
obviously all have started up at the
reading Gators you know it's all good
last Housewives question the ladies have
obviously had a lot to say about you and
what unfolds this season and spoken a
lot on your behalf it seems you have
stayed relatively quiet said stay tuned
see how it unfolds judge for yourself
is there any misconception you want to
clarify that they've your co-stars have
may be put out there well first of all
part of why I want to stay quiet is I'm
one that likes to I come from a scripted
world and you let usually the teasers
and all that hopefully the viewers will
come and watch the show and let it play
out on television and not in the media
or on social media so that's where I
wanted people to just watch the show I
didn't want to be able anything you know
the only thing let us know that I quit
the show or movie at their reunion or my
co-stars I bet you anything shows a show
for the reunion well moving off of
housewives
that's crazy time you've gone and
launched a whole new business CB me why
skincare and why now it's actually been
two years in the making and I always
been passionate about skin care and and
taking care of my skin so it's 15 years
old I've always been very adamant about
keeping my face out of the Sun sunscreen
and clean living and just really taking
good care of my skin and I think now is
also a wonderful time to launch it a lot
of us can't go get our facials and do
our usual skin care regime and and I
think the products are very user
friendly so it was definitely something
you know now is the time to bring it out
there and tell me a little bit about the
products and how it's different from
what's on the mark
it was important for me to have a hemp
seed oil part of the line so there's a
lot of benefits with it and that's one
of the main ingredients in the line
which is very important for me you are
one of the most striking people in
person that I've ever seen in person
oh and I saw you recently shut down like
all that speculation over Botox and
fillers and all that and what would you
say is the biggest beauty misconception
about you oh well a lot of people say
I'm having plastic surgery on my face
which I haven't
I did try Botox I personally did not
like it I liked how I looked very rested
that I loved but I personally I didn't
like how it felt just to clear my face I
felt like someone was pushing down I
don't know
the third bazaar and also I'm very
expressive eyebrows and and I'm an
actress and I guys even if it's annoying
I still and I use a lot of expressions
for my face so that was something I felt
like I couldn't do as much so that's
also that's why I personally for me I
don't like how it feels I but I do love
the way it looks very must have you've
also taken this time to work on your
quantum reach foundation can you talk to
me about the mission of that
organization and what you're doing with
it actually the dinner that Erin and I
hosted at our home on the house bias we
have just finished finalizing everything
that we needed to do to launch the
foundation we're very excited to tell
the women again I know not everything
you know makes it on air and it's a
foundation called planned regions
research education animal children
health and you know it's our way of
trying to give back and healthy does it
utilize with all the technology that
Erin uses in his business is it related
to that at all or is it separate it's
everything you know it's us trying to
help get back and help people with
children that are dealing with issues
physically but also there's a lot of
swimming there
our bullying issues emotional issues so
you know we touch on all of that when
you put together some programs for that
a lot of what Aaron does and all the
research and the people that he has that
are amazing them together and something
we're very excited about sounds like a
very holistic full picture sort of thing
thank you
were you surprised at the reaction to
Aaron kind of explaining what he does
for a living to people I break down
stuff so you can all kill you I don't
kill anybody by the way I remove blocks
discord information at that moment in
the dinner you know I knew youth is
always about know your audience while
we're eating and at that Center be the
dinner for this so we're gonna wrap up
the conversation and then I'm sure
you're also eating to get back to work
acting and I know Bouldin the beautiful
like everything else was shut down in
all this do you have any idea when you
guys might be able to do something again
or is it what's gonna shut down and how
we you know especially being actors
having 60 you know the social just I
don't know how it's gonna you know it's
up in the air and I obviously like
everyone else you know I'm obviously
anxious like everyone else to get back
to get back to working yeah when I was
thinking about this I was like how I
mean so sorry known for love scenes
fight scenes
how are those gonna happen we all have
to wear masks I don't know
I mean that's the thing with our
industry being actors and entertainment
and doing all this do it's a it's a big
challenge we're all of close proximity
with each other so I'm not sure I think
we're all trying to figure out last time
I checked in with you you said Eloise's
day-to-day really hadn't been
interrupted by this is that still the
case is she still
well she's doing great she's so excited
the whole family's oh she has no idea
what's going on she just knows every
it's everyone's home together perfectly
long time it's a long way I love it
no I've been loving you shared a video
of her just giggling in the yard the
other day like that's so sweet I love
seeing it keep sharing everything I
hopefully we get back to normal soon
Congrats on CB me thank you and then
we'll talk soon I guess maybe in another
eight weeks when we're still in
[Music]